[Music]
foreign
we're back doing an open andrew yang is
on the podcast andrew yang
come on i am the fact that we're getting
like very fancy politicians on the show
the fact that we made it the fact that a
politician would talk to anyone
in this room is truly a shocker
i mean i can't imagine the interview
coming up with andrew yang is so
informative
full disclosure i was very nervous and i
act really weird in the interview i
was stuttering i was constantly fixing
my hair
i was super unprofessional and a little
hungover
i like that you came up to andrew yang
like this and we're like be on my
podcast and he was like well we have to
help everyone
you know for him this was a charity
initiative it was like you know the
circus is suffering
i gotta be honest with you so before i
interviewed andrew yang i couldn't sleep
because i was nervous and remember i was
out of sleeping pills
yes yes and i took
one of my dog's gabapentins which is
like
a dog sedative or like a pain medication
sure you want to say all this
yeah i'm saying it i'm real i don't lie
to our fans i tell them
what's what i'm not gonna pretend to be
perfect even though i come off that way
i know you think i'm perfect guys
i know i know i'm giving away all my
secrets right now no i took
i got so nervous that i wasn't gonna
fall asleep so i took a little bit of
like old nyquil from when i was sick in
january
nyquil i know i love it i can't believe
that shit's legal
and then i went into my dog's like
medicine cabinet and took a gabapentin
and the expiration date was like 2017 so
i took like a weird old painkiller
and i felt really odd during the
interview i bet you did yeah
plus being like kind of nervous and kind
of stuttery she said is anybody else's
spirit left their body
am i the only one who can see myself
from above remember the producers after
the interview i was like you guys i
think that was a disaster i think i
totally embarrassed myself like i found
myself stuttering but
usually when i think i'm moving slow or
can't say something properly i'm
actually speaking at like a normal speed
even though in my head it sounds like
i'm like in slow motion or like in
quicksand
i listen back to it i'm like oh no that
makes perfect yeah like because i'm like
oh my god i can't remember this word
you're such an idiot
and then that's how it feels in my head
but i'm actually just talking in a
lucid way is how it comes off
the pills probably didn't help any
though the pills certainly didn't help i
just i
shouldn't wait for this podcast it's do
not take your dog's
drugs to wait on your prescription which
is whitney's
biggest fault she doesn't understand
that you can't call a pharmacy but i
need my pills now
they're like man we can't just give you
more pills and she's like i don't
understand
but i'm but i can't fall but i'm thai
thai and they were like we gave you
enough to last this month
i lost them i do sometimes drop them
or i had to take like one and a half one
night because
like you can't self-medicate man i'm
just like we're in a pandemic can't we
be a little flexible about these rules
like what's so funny i'm not gonna like
sue you let's just be cool about one of
my favorite things every time you're
like is my prescription ready and i'm
like i don't think it's ready and you go
fuck
[Laughter]
i can't believe this this is fucking
annoying you guys know me google me you
know why i need this early
like i'm going to tell them that can you
google her really quick
it's just like now i can't sleep because
my prescription's not ready it's undoing
the whole point of this drive
yeah and now i'm panicking so i need
anxiety medication but that's not ready
all of them just be like hey
this is on you if you don't give it to
me i'm gonna take a nyquil and it's
my dog's drug so your call you just call
me like you're gonna stay on the phone
with me all night
so can you lull me to sleep if you won't
give me my sleeping pills yeah you
better learn how to whisper i just like
to try to like guilt them and like
appeal to their conscience if you don't
give this to me i'm going to take some
like
old weird rose we're medical
professionals
she's like heard of them remember when
um we had to get my prozac prescription
and you said they were like on back
order
oh yeah i'm very i'm i have a lot of
questions about i called
three different pharmacies and they were
like it's a shortage in l.a right now
and i was like that's such an
la thing to say there's a shortage of
prozac in los angeles yeah in the south
they'd be like
we don't even know what that is we're
like laying in the yard trying to see
what's what shape is that cloud there's
some moonshine at the yard sale down the
street what's your problem why do you
need prozac
okay anyway we want you to get to andrew
yang as soon as possible because i think
the interview is super
uh besides me being a little groggy
um he's super incisive and he seemed
completely sober
um that's a great way to lure listeners
in we want you to get past this part as
quick as possible
well no we just haven't done an open in
so long and everyone wants to hear from
benton
we have a couple announcements to make
unfortunately because of this goddamn
invisible murderer called kovid the
houston and house of blues shows that
were scheduled i believe in march
are being canceled i mean they're
canceling march shows i always thought
the invisible murder was a tooth fairy
[Laughter]
i didn't think that that's so funny to
me and i can't explain why
um house of blues show in houston is
canceled however if you're listening to
this podcast
there's a very strong chance that we are
going to do some outdoor
shows in late september early october
on the east coast a couple uh in the
midwest
we're driving we're going to take a
couple flights safely
a tandem bike yeah
[Laughter]
whenever we have a broomstick um so
check
the website whitneycummings.com i'm also
going to do text alerts i know this is
boring annoying logistical stuff i hate
it as much as you do but 818-239-7527
text me text me your questions your
comments
your dick pics your bathroom pics you
know i'll start a fight with her start
honestly a lot of people have they want
to they
they people want to challenge me about
how shiny i am a lot of people don't
like my new look
they don't like my new gla blue light
glasses
if you have notes about me or my
personality critiques criticisms
why do it publicly in the comments i'm
not going to look at those text me
directly
if you want to hurt my feelings that's
the way to really do it yeah if you have
notes about me or my personality hang
out with my parents
because they'll agree with them and also
if you see horse shirts at a vintage
store you text that to me text me the
vintage store and i'll fucking order it
a lot of you have been doing that
and i appreciate it quite frankly you
guys have become my stylist
oh half the horse shirts and weird-ass
horse jewelry i wear
i get texted people go i saw this and
thought of you and i went yeah right
bitch
i'm gonna start blocking those people
818-239-7527
you can text me you put your city in so
when i'm coming to your city and when
there's updates
during all this coveted madness i can
say directly hey this show just happened
it's rescheduled
here's the deal you can you know it's a
drive-in it's a
you know we're doing a lot of like on
grass like the way you do a festival
like it's a picnic
it's just like it's just like a better
way to connect because sometimes you
know social media
sometimes we don't get an algorithm no
sometimes you're on the algorithm and
you miss it and then you're mad
yeah and then you're like why the fuck
didn't you come to my city and i'm like
bitch i was there last week
stop you muted me you muted me because i
was posting too many pink hair photos
um anyway so those are the logistics
check the website
oh we have more logistics oh what we
have new merch coming out next month oh
you in the merge
me and the merch you and the merch um
take it away i apologize
yeah but yeah we have new merch coming
out next month we've been working on new
merch and it is
i will say kind of a minute a strong
departure from what we've been
doing yup yup yup and it's a lot of
fresh
looks it's a lot of fresh looks and hot
uh taglines yeah it's hot deadlines
fresh foods
fresh fresh lukes uh it's a lot of stuff
you've been asking for that's right and
a lot of stuff you
you didn't know you wanted a lot of
stuff frankly that might get you fired
a lot of things that will not work in
the dress code of your
business a lot of stuff that'll help you
leave subtle hands
a lot of stuff that you should never
wear on a first date
[Music]
but there's there's uh wolves with merch
on it wolves with blue eyeliner
we have fans coming bent and show no no
we don't have fans stop lying
we're waiting on those okay but we do
have we will have fans if you're
watching
uh if you're listening you're not gonna
be able to see this bent and do it do
the fan
do it now bam oh
isn't that bone chilling bone chest so
satisfied
i encourage you to see what benton just
did
uh on youtube sexy it is so powerful
it it i'm just saying what i suppose was
written
with you in that fandom everyone should
get a family i have a theory if you any
argument you're just like did you did
you eat my sandwich with my name on
it yes you did okay i'm sorry you're
right i did you're right
i'm sorry exactly thank you you're i
just got this got heated and now you're
cooling it down
yeah oh mona gets really triggered by
the fan mona is my dog who's now
a panicking monologues jokes
news we are a serious news organization
now
we are seriously organizing we are i i
honestly believe
that our news is the most truthful
and scientifically correct
you guys are pitching names for our news
segments uh very true news
pretty good barely news not bad
news is the question mark is this news
anyone news is this thing on news
uh frank news because my dog's name is
frank and he always interrupts the news
program and it is frank news
turns out all those names were taken by
the actual networks
i believe we are the least biased news
network out there at this point oh we
have to be
i was watching cnn the other day excuse
me c frank always has to participate in
this
i was watching um uh cnn the other day
and the anchor was reading
the news and was sighing and rolling his
eyes
it's true that's actually relatable mood
i know but you can't you can't do that
you can be like anyway
so this vote passed oh god damn
republicans like you can't do that
you're a news acre
you're another fire i guess yeah you're
not allowed to roll your eyes you know
what i mean
it's almost like like you're just eating
skittles i'm waiting for them to get to
the point where
they where they make that jerk-off
motion you know when you have a
conversation like i guess that law pass
passed
fucking blow hearts just voted on it you
can't do that
this is the news or they like put things
in quotes anyway that law
passed in the senate you can impeach
yeah you can't do air quotes around
things
like it's i believe we are actually the
most direct non-biased news source at
this point
um so give us the top what's our top
story
bring it home we're going to start off
with this is this is some hard hitting
news hard hitting news
it's hard rock hard news
i like my news like i like my dicks rock
hard i like mine in picture form
[Laughter]
lavender sales they're up during the
pandemic people are buying more lavender
to calm themselves and
hopefully help fight off uh evils the
spirits i guess
this is where we're at as a society like
honestly
i'm very worried that no one's gonna
take the vaccine because people are
buying lavender
as a medical remedy we've gone back to
witchcraft we've literally
like we've come full circle urban
outfitters won
they've won i'm i'm very concerned
of where we're going in terms of putting
our faith
in uh potpourri uh potpourri
and crystals like we're in a pandemic
let's focus on
actual true science let's when the
vaccine comes you guys can please take
it
don't go you know what i already have
that lavender bath oil
why would i need an actual vaccine i
whisper all my fears into a box
why would i need this vaccine when i've
already got this
salt lamp right here i lay in the moon
every night
people can't touch me you know it's just
stress is the worst thing in the world
on the immune system you know what's
stressful
paying 18 for lavender oil
oh it's not it smells gross it smells
like the girl who invites you to bible
camp and then talk shit about everybody
in the prayer circle
i can't relate to that that's very much
you should we should speaking of
betterhelp.com
you should log in very much like what
that is i want to know what herb keeps
people that buy lavender away from me
[Laughter]
weed oh okay it's my guess
but i just i'm very concerned like i
know we're in peak stress i know we're
in peak anxiety but i hope we still
believe in science after all of this
like i think we're getting to
uh uh sort of hokey wellness
you know like i don't know if it's
instagram i don't know you know what it
is but
i'm just i i just really hope you guys
are taking care of your immune
immune systems eating well hydrating
yourself
instead of just using a dildo made of
turquoise and thinking that's going to
cure kovacs listen if lavender worked
salem would have been a lot different
because they had actual uh that's the
thing
lavender's been around for thousands of
years and it has not done
anything for the general vibe of humans
it has
so i'm i'm anti-lavender
this does feel like news because i feel
some hate mail coming on
i know this is a hot take dude wouldn't
you just try to cancel lavender i know
i just know a lot of people that are
like super stressed out and super
anxious and they don't take care of
themselves
and they eat crap and they don't
exercise and they don't hydrate
themselves
but i just got a fucking lavender
inhaler i'm good i'm carrying rose
quartz in my bra
but what's the news around this what was
it
we didn't know oh
because they're more stressed out people
understood that the first thing we said
oh do you think okay because i'm
confused i just thought we were talking
about lavender
what else is on the docket benton well
um
as you can tell i didn't have a lot of
time to prepare for this
it's been a busy week i recorded like
three podcasts this week
so many dates i've done a lot no i did
joe rogan this week i didn't have time
to
uh uh research last year as you can
probably tell
and no one needs to so that's great yeah
uh the news
i'll get to it the news you do the work
you tell us what's going on oh i just
hit my
mouth on the mic well you saw britney
spears uh-huh wants to end her uh
conservative shit big and then this is a
very hot
story okay and a lot of people want to
free britney
i feel like i'm going to get canceled uh
after talking about this but
i started following her on instagram and
it makes me
very anxious it makes me very unsettled
i was looking at them and the thing that
really upset me that made me think that
she's either unhinged or something is
very wrong is that she did three
separate posts on three separate days in
the same
shirt yeah with the first friendly queen
but i'm just saying for some
reason that to me made me think
something was deeply wrong
when she shaved her head i was like oh
we all have bad days we all want to just
i i've felt the urge to do that before i
get that smashed a car with umbrella
we've all seen our boyfriends get a text
from an ex and
thought about we've all we've all been
there we've all listened to too many
adele songs yeah
smashing a car but seeing her in the
same top
in three different photos in three
different days i was like there's
something wrong with this girl
there's something terribly terribly
wrong because that's something it's her
dad
that's some aunt shit that's some like
that that's a that's something that only
an
aunt or a dad would do it made me think
that he's in control of her
yeah that's very much like this is my
good shirt also yes but also i think
he's
i feel like he's doing her social media
no i don't know any woman controls
everything that is saying that would do
that also her captions
obviously written by a guy there's like
the heart emoji the rose emoji a panda
a panda emoji like no women do that
they're just like talking about she's
just talking about colors like i love
the color
no but she's also so positive it's like
i'm so happy to be alive and my life is
so great like no woman would ever write
life is going great it's just way too
positive i just don't know any women
that would never a white straight man is
writing that clearly
it's a white straight man that has
access
to a lot of money who's like nothing's
wrong no woman would ever
act like that and speaking of what her
dad is doing uh how can i get you on
this program
me yeah on what on conservatorship on
the conservatorship thing i get the
point of it
i mean the idea is to basically control
her finances and contr i could benefit
from that we need someone to veto plaid
shirts
yeah we need someone to come in and
intervene in my wardrobe and my captions
quite frankly and manage my money i mean
i
when i first started making i get why
they have this in place it's to make
sure she doesn't blow all of her money
like when i first started making money i
just started like paying for like
dogs dental surgeries and i was like
broke so i get why
they don't let people in their 20s have
a lot of money we make would make
if i had no one helping me manage
my money uh so many people would be dead
listen and i would have like four
elephants in my backyard i mean
someone does have to come in and make
sure that creatives emotional people
don't just have a blank check
but it shouldn't be your parents imagine
if your parents were still buying your
clothes
no but yeah i'm just saying like there's
britney spears and then there's jake
paul
which is the other extreme of like
someone needs to intervene on that
oh my god i just i am convinced that he
is writing her captions because also the
spacing is off this is the kind of shit
i notice it'll be like hey everybody
space three exclamation points another
space
and then a period i'm like this is a
dad that drinks too much this is the dad
with a holster phone yeah this is a dad
this is a dad that still has the
bluetooth in his ear just
all the time even when he's not on the
phone he's making calls about her money
and writing things he wants to
also look at who she follows she only
follows
people that dad's it's like pitbull
mariah carey
kenny loggins like she doesn't even
follow like young
celebrities just like professional
golfers and baseball player
like totally it's like tony robbins and
like
like it's just like um shania twain why
is she following tommy bahama
yeah so weird she follows margaritaville
that is really funny why did she follow
the rainforest cafe this is a random
follow-up also
you can tell her dad is fully
controlling her life because
they said he's controlled since 2008
which is the same time she reapplied
that eyeliner
what is happening i have i
truly we're not like shaming her we're
not shaming her looks
she's an icon of legendary i know of
course we love brazil her dad
i truly believe that she is not allowed
to go out or like go on the internet
because
everything she it's very 90s like
everything that she wear her makeup like
you never see her
in like you know the very forward
fashion look that for example
i have trademarked like blue eyeliner
you never see
true you never see her doing hip cool
stuff like that but no you never see her
in like
modern clothes she's still wearing stuff
from her first tour she's still here
they're like recycle them she's still
wearing stuff from bb
that i got dry humped in when i was 15.
i mean she's still wearing these midriff
peasant tops and this is how i
know that she is not allowed like near
things or to make decisions
all of those peasant tops look real
closely zoom in on the photos
there the there's always a um like a the
hanger string the hanger string that
that they put on the store to keep it on
the hanger yeah that you cut off the
second you get home they aren't cut off
they're hanging out of her shirts which
means they don't let her around scissors
they don't like keys they don't let her
around knives
there is no woman that would not cut off
those hanger strings from a brand new
top it's the first thing you do when you
get home
also all these crop top peasant tops
that's what she's saying that three
times she's trying to con
it's her dad is buying her peasant tops
to try to convince her that she's poor
yeah just a lowly peasant yeah it's like
she's an icon why is she dressed like an
extra in like the my
my little house in the prairie porn
parody
[Music]
oh god like what is that is so small the
chokers
the chokers straight from claire's very
90s like she's always wearing two
chokers and i'm convinced they're
tracking devices
maybe they're like shot callers or
something definitely who's wearing
chokers
i mean the kids the kids these days yeah
but hers
they're not her chokers hers are hers
are the plastic woven
chokers yeah those are they were made in
the same factory as slap bracelets
the ones that she has it's all very 90s
they're not like the new cool chokers
like they're the ones we
wore when we were like doing whippets
at raves i mean when i was a kid
i knew that she i mean i knew it was
trouble when she made that video where
she was like
so guys i burnt my gem down um you know
i had two candles and one thing led to
another
also see her reading something i feel
like yeah she feels like someone's
holding up a white board or like cards
or something yeah and they're always
filming from the top
the highest angle they can't she's
totally reading something yeah because
if she could say what she wanted to
she'd be like so guys i burnt my gym
down um you know i had two candles and
one thing led to another and
uh i had to set myself on fire so my dad
let me leave the house
like it's like what else could she say
but she also says it was like no emotion
it's like it's almost like
feels like you know i don't know she's
like not allowed to have a personality
she's not like i'mma write gym down
it's like she's like anyway i burnt my
gym down and now i'm doing this thing
and now i have to redo my gym anyway so
now i'm gonna show you my exercises
like when she said she's like a little
robot i have two candles and you know
one thing leads to another
she said that yeah hellfire also her can
i tell you something i'm now we're going
on a tangent
her exercises aren't even 20 20. she
doesn't even have like new machines in
there
she's on like she's like doing these
like you know remember you know that
thing that's all over
instagram of jamie lee curtis and john
travolta doing those exercises her
exercises are literally like
calisthenics from the 70s from like a
video it's almost like she's a kid she's
like what she switches and it just spins
around yeah she's just you know
she's like spinning and like doing like
weird exercises with like no
weights no she's like a hill click
there's yeah there's no there's no like
yoga ball there's no like modern
machinery
like you look at the rocks gym and it
looks like a badass like gold's gym it's
got like all the new stuff like she
doesn't even have that she's like doing
jumping jacks and like you know there's
newer exercises
yeah why we let's help her what are we
gonna do i love him here's what i'll say
okay devil's advocate
girl devil's advocate brittany if you're
listening if you're a fan of the pop oh
also
this is what we'll do she doesn't follow
a lot of people on instagram
let's do this brittany if you need help
follow me on instagram do you think
she's allowed to listen to this because
well someone might get to her let's get
this because a lot of people say we said
like
they were like britney wear black if you
need help oh yeah wear yellow shorts
like eight days in a row she wore yellow
the next day like but
that's a little bit could be
coincidental she always kind of wears
yellow well she also made a whole post
about yellow
she she posted just the color yellow and
then wrote how much she loves yellow in
the caption
that's wild that's wild yeah so
for her free hair if you follow us we
will
get in a car we will drive down there
right now
and benton will fight your dad i'll
knock on the door politely
and i'll ask you you can go get some ice
cream with us we will first reapply your
eyeliner because that does
it i i know a wet and wild
runny teary drip when i see one i mean
that
that is that's a good description i have
cried in wet and wild
a lot that is not nars that is wet and
wild making yeah
i mean she is not getting new makeup a
cultural icon i know but here's what
i'll say devil's advocate britney spears
little devil's advocate if you've been
in that
weird-ass marble bunker for the last i
don't know
20 years now is probably not the time to
emerge
oh i'm just saying like maybe
maybe even another six months the idea
that she like is finally like
i'm free i'm free and she goes out and
everyone's like put on a fucking mask
bitch and she's like jesus i'd rather go
back into my
fortress with my uh uh full year-round
christmas tree she's like the last time
i was out here i was bald eating cheetos
barefoot like this is so different
yeah like what happened why is everybody
such an asshole
yeah like we don't like pepsi no more
y'all
yeah we're like wash your hands bitch
like it's you're you're coming
you're being freed at a weird time they
all think she's a mennonite in this book
yeah it's just like protests and riots
everywhere
it's just like it's a lot anyway i feel
like we've talked a lot about britney
spears what else can we inform
our fans with so they they are up to
date
what's next benton
um sorry i didn't write anything for any
of this i'm just winging it the next
thing
did you know what that flushing urinals
can spread kovid
yeah no shit big question who's ever
flushed a urinal
you ever been in a men's bathroom the p
is just on the floor
whoever wrote this article has never
been in a men's restroom also hot take
journals are pointless we don't need to
line up beside each other and piss in a
trough
you can pee in a toilet it takes a
little more work you have to aim
like work for something in your life
dude that is the stupidest
waste of space in the bathroom i hate a
fucking urinal it is so weird that you
guys are shoulder to shoulder with your
dicks out
it is such a weird choice
like what do you need to talk about with
your dick in your hand like that with
your friend what are you doing you're so
pissed off
i'm tired i've had a lot of traumatic
experiences in bathrooms but hold on i'm
actually researching this because i'm a
real journalist
according to a report in the physics of
fluids journal my memoir first of all
the biggest
the biggest takeaway of this is there's
a journal called the physics of fluids
okay i wouldn't know what other fluids
are in that journey i know i i would
like to subscribe to this publication
this is already my favorite magazine
researchers found a flushing urinal can
blast covered particles
two feet in the air potentially
infecting the unsuspecting urinal users
how i'm sorry two feet in the air
wouldn't
how you'd have to be very short for this
mouth like how far does urinals
how far does piss backsplash once again
no one's ever peed in the urinal it's on
the floor
i am telling you there's there's just
piss all over men's bathrooms
the urinal doesn't matter oh you know
what i hate about your nose that little
brick that's in it
the air freshener is that what it is
yeah that is so disgusting you know you
don't have to put an air pressure in a
toilet
because the p doesn't sit there for days
so now experts are suggesting during the
pandemic people should wear face
coverings
in public restrooms okay well
years ago when i was hanging around in
bathrooms wearing masks everyone thought
i was weird
and look how that's changed look how
that's changed look at me now they also
suggest that they sit down to pee which
like asking to do to sit down to pee is
like
like ask them to flush the urinal
they're only gonna do it when they're
alone do guys sit down to pee
if i saw a guy sit down i'd think he was
taking it poo poo
well what if they were just sitting down
there just holding a little penis back
pain in the toilet like this can you
just sit down on a toilet and pee
without
like touching your penis or what um
i mean i think some people i think it
depends on the size of your dick
if you have like a little pin i think
you like take a little square toilet
paper and like put it between like the
you know so it's like touching the rim
of the toilet bowl
no but you would scoop maybe that's why
people don't like toilets now then
thinking about it
well women toilets are very sexist to
women the way that you sit
actually makes it so that you don't
after you empty your entire bladder so
you're actually supposed to either
elevate your knees or lean forward as if
you were like squatting in a hole
like that is the only way to completely
empty your bladder and make
poo poos properly so it's toilets are
bad for women
but can men sit on them and pee i mean
you can't
thought about it you definitely can do
that but i think that
i think that you it would i mean i'm
pretty sure your penis would like lay on
the top of it a little bit or in it
or it would it have to put this out of
your opinion you have a giant dick
mentioned no that's why i'm saying i
can't comment on this because i never
think about my penis that much
but i'm sure there's some do does your
penis touch the toilet bowl producers
i'm just saying wouldn't it just go
downward is this sexual harassment
sorry you guys if you need to talk to a
lawyer i'll give you the number but can
i just i have no power
so like can you pee sitting down
you got to push your dick you have to
hold it so then it would touch the
little rim of the toilet bowl right
no how far forward are you you would say
you can't sit that far back on the
toilet can you
yes no you're not the edge of it you're
just in the whole toilet
dumped you just sit on the edge
with your legs crossed if there was room
you have to push it back is my point
yes okay so you so when you sit down to
pee you gotta kind of like touch your
dick
yeah like to push it down interesting
i'm sure yeah
i wouldn't do that in front of your
girlfriend just fyi
or anyone really or anyone really don't
what yeah
really men do a pee when they take a
dump dump
dude girls not but so you have to hold
your dick when you take a dump
oh god you guys have to touch your dicks
when you take shits
oh you mean you just put it what what is
it like putty you just put it down and
then it just stays
really because the toilet seat you know
what it is you know what i'm realizing
girls don't get to see flaccid dicks
that much you guys
like are weird about it you'll like cut
you only want us to see it when they're
rock hard like our news so i don't know
anything about the behavior of dicks
when they're not
hard well that was my point your flaccid
dick is like
if you're if you're a shower and not a
grower and your flaccid dick is like
hanging over your balls
then you can like put it down there
easily if you have a little like
grower penis it's like a little nub that
sits above your balls right
yeah well yeah like i like those penises
that are like hey i'm up here
they're like buttons they're just like
it's like
they're like butts they're like inside
of you like hello i like them like
little mushrooms like it's
there's something so i think that's this
is not the point of this conversation
this is the kind of news that people
need to know i did not know that
i have lots of questions about dicks
because
i feel like i've spent so much time in
relationships trying to like not look
because guys get insecure about it or
whatever so
thank you for letting me ask these
questions i've learned a lot you should
probably think them i don't know if i
helped that much
um no you created a safe space i am a
safe space
okay me i'm sweating too i'm so hot
we have that was embarrassing okay
first andrew yang's oh my gosh we just
talked about dicks for in urinals for 20
minutes and like
smart people that want to hear andrew
yang had to sit through that i'm sorry
yeah but you know those people have
dicks maybe something
and then the biggest thing the last
thing that we have to discuss
is the wuhan pool party the wuhan pool
part you know the best way to celebrate
surviving a pandemic is start a new one
that is crazy to me that's a perfect
joke benton
thank you i can't follow that i mean
having a pool party during a pandemic is
like
it's like bullying a shooter during a
school shooting you're just making it
worse
like this is what caused the problem
i mean they're celebrating not having
any cases in like three months and in
america we're just we're just fucking
celebrating we have no reason to but
we're still fucking partying
i mean it's crazy i would that pool had
to be filled with rubbing alcohol
right i don't know i think it was would
you get in the pool well you ain't
getting your own pulse i guess not
yes i do i got in the pool the other day
for photos
for the gram would you go this pool
party if you were invited would you be
the celebrity guest at the luhan pool
party
what are they paying me hospital visits
no i don't think i would i i generally
don't like pool
parties outside of pandemics because all
i can think about are pubes floating
around
in shorts and then going into my
crevices
you think about genitals a lot i do yeah
as a woman you have to
that's the trauma that's the trauma of
the dna like our ours is like a
a hole i mean you really it's a whole no
women's
genitals are a complex i know magical
there is an
entry point for pretty much anything at
any time
we are it's a open there's an entry
point
in men's genitals all the time no but
like a pubes not gonna like go up into
your dickhole
you know some pislets are little and
some are larger pistols yeah what's a
pistol
that's the part you pee out of the
little slut dickholes are different
sizes
yeah so i know that i know my way around
the dickhole
i just wanted to bring it back today no
i'm just saying like when i'm in like
because you always have to worry about
getting like a uti or yeast infection
like you have to just think about it
because you've got this like
open you know penises
i don't know infections i don't know
maybe skin yeast but there's not we have
a but can a little hole get a yeast
infection of holes
i know you're a barrel i got it i know
we are swiss cheese
so we have to i have to think about that
stuff so i generally get too much
chlorine can throw off your ph levels
like i don't even like going to pools if
there's too much chlorine
yeah too much sunshine the wind yeah i
never want my pussy to be too clean you
know i just want to make sure it's sort
of
i want the ecosystem to say good for the
turtles really
i don't want the livestock in there to
die you can balance wearing bathing
suits they get
you know it's a it's it gets dicey what
is the vagina's like an aquarium there's
like a little rock there's a chest in
there some moss
it's a full ego there's like sea monkeys
like you don't even know
like what are you describing i'm just
saying you have to think about this
kind of stuff you know so i i wouldn't
go to that pool party
before all this nightmare well i
wouldn't go either
that make you feel better that's why we
get and that's the news guys
andrew yang is next i love him so so
much you're gonna learn
so much from this um i tried to shut my
whore mouth
uh a bit so that you guys could hear uh
his amazing messages
and thoughts and solutions be sure to
vote also make sure you register to vote
and you vote early
if you can can you vote early now i mean
can you
have researched it before you bring it
up i hear a lot of people talk about
voting and
all i know how to do it i vote on my own
hollywood celebrity that tells americans
to vote guys can you donate money we
have to
we have to save something or someone so
register to vote is that what you have
these glasses on it changing i mean you
are because i was like
i take responsibility guys whenever the
voting situation is i did it
do you want to start speaking the
imagine song too is there anything else
you want to do
queen of the night that's me do you want
to start selling crystal water bottles
at any point
you fucking this candle smells like my
asshole
my dickhole my easter no we have to go
we have
andrew yang love you guys like subscribe
don't ride elephants
enjoy andrew yang this podcast will make
you smarter
and more hopeful and you can impress
people
uh on your zoom brunches
whitneycomings.com
store for merch oh that's right we now
take a break
to talk about i feel fun and fresh
pantaloons
pantaloons bloomers mandy's are truly
the only underwear that i have at this
point i have no other underwear can i
tell you something about mandy's
you have to they paid you too i
went on a hike a date hike i think i'd
like to think it was a date hike the
other day
it's a big thing we do in la and the
underwear
i chose to wear on my date hike as to
not show any lines
or get any weird swampage
or any weird sticky embarrassing
front wedgies or back wedgies or lines
or anything
picked my meundies and i gotta say i
think my me undies that are
they're purple with like a teal line
they're like an eggplant purple yeah
they're me lucky me undies now do you
think just wearing those underwear got
you a second date or
i think it was the myani's it could have
been my personality
i mean i don't know how else i could
have but
i am honestly going to take this
opportunity
to say why the hell haven't you ordered
me more
you have a subscription they come every
month i know but are you still you got
multiple subscribers
yeah i kind of do my i have a problem
with this company can we buy
more at once can you you know i never
checked but i bet you can't surely
like i would like my only problem with
this is i only get one no you totally
can because i just recently bought uh
the undershirts and the socks too oh
the socks are so legit the best so soft
and they don't i love because they don't
you know when you're like walking around
and you have the
the lower i'm getting choked up talking
about my miandi's um
they're beautiful when socks you know
when they freaking sneak down into your
shoes
these never do that they never do they
like sneak down and then they're
halfway in your shoe also why are you
wearing knee-high socks
because i am a sexy person
because that's what sexy people do i
play a lot of tennis
i'm a catholic school girl who knew i'm
a cam girl now
so me undies you guys know that i i tend
to not read copy because i want to be
authentic
and from the heart and these undies have
captured my heart
me undies um i'm obsessed but we do need
to talk about some actual details so you
know where to purchase them
i mean the thing that i love about them
the most is that i'm not someone who
like you like like fun underwear like
you're into the prints and the patterns
yeah all that stuff i don't like that
and i have so they have classic like
just classic colors if you're just like
you know me um just do you do black
i do just the black gray red white and
then one called goblin green which i
feel like maybe a reed i kind of love
that
yeah or goblin blue or something like
that i love it i love that
there's a you know it's just it's like i
don't know i just feel like we're
spending
i'm taking like a whole new look at my
like under
garments now that it's all i i mean i
walk around in my underwear all day now
because we don't have
we don't get to go anywhere they have
onesies now too oh really which
i mean why don't you get me one of those
we show up in onesies on this show
that'll be i'll never wear anything else
it's also like i'm not even joking they
feel
like velvety like like um
like what do they feel like velvet
don't even know what they're i don't
know do they even tell what they're made
of yeah yeah
right here we should read the ad at some
point it's it starts with sustainably
sourced beechwood trees that
magically turn from pulp to yarn to
undies undies that kind of feel like
heaven on your skin
comfort from the outside literally to in
does that mean trees were so soft i know
keep your undies uh drawer stocked with
the me undies membership a subscription
that sends new pairs right to your door
plus get statewide savings on exclusive
sales me undies has a great offer for my
people any first-time purchasers you're
going to get 15
off and free shipping no-brainer
especially because
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that makes sense and people will
complain about everything
for 100 of the consumers to like
something that means they have to be
doubly amazing because i feel like these
days people will take any opportunity
to say they don't like something and
people will send anything to your house
nowadays
like you can get anything just delivered
to you and so this is one of those
companies where when you saw when you
see that
and you see it's 100 and it comes to
your door you're like
no i need it no i have to be honest with
you my day starts with how my underwear
feels
if you put on a pair of underwear and
you're like ah my butt like oh
god like you know what i mean it just
sets the tone for your entire day
yeah i'm so happy you quit wearing
burlap underwear
i stopped wearing the bob wire thongs
and so like it's just you put them on
you're like
boom they're like tight they fit you
know what i like about the elastic
doesn't
tear stretch you know after you have
underwear for a little while they start
getting like baggy and weird
shorts yes these are my basketball
shorts yes they become like a kerchief
and so uh you i've started using half of
my old underwears like masks at this
point because they don't even fit
anymore
we've truly talked about underwear so
long it's not like we have a fetish i
know so getting to get your 15
off your first pair and free shipping
i'm authentic
i'm real i don't just read the ads
okay i lose the product i'm not a hacky
phony i did such a good impression last
time you really did
to get your 15 off your first pair free
shipping and 100
satisfaction guaranteed go to
meetundies.com
whitney that's meundies.com whitney
better help okay i don't know about you
but i'm tired of carrying crystals in my
brawl
and better help us really fix that
i've saved so much time now that i don't
have to sage my body before i leave the
house
you don't have to do your wicked rituals
anymore no more you don't have to i've
stopped praying for the moon for your
cauldrons
yeah better help they fixed it you know
that on this podcast
we almost exclusively talk about mental
health or lack thereof
it's ours because we're trying to find
it biggest priority we're in a constant
search
for sanity thank god for better help
you know i'm the first person to say
that when people in the public eye talk
about
therapy and my therapist it's like okay
most people don't have
three hours a week to drive to a
therapist
pay 700 you know it's just it doesn't
the
you know i feel like the traditional
model of therapy in person is just set
up to actually make you more stressed
out
and more anxious it's like well most of
my anxiety is about money so why am i
gonna go to therapists and spend all
this and there's so much going on right
now that everybody's kind of looking for
a therapist so it's kind of hard to find
one so it's nice to be able to like
connect with someone from your home it's
also by the way
the in the old days you just like asked
a friend for a therapist and you would
just go to some therapist and you're
just like oh i guess i have to stick
with this person because i've already
been here a couple times what am i going
to start over like
now you can actually find someone
on better betterhelp that matches with
you you can look at a bunch like it just
makes so much more
sense because you actually know what's
out there you can start communicating in
under 48 hours which is
in my experience whenever i need a
therapist i'm like i need to talk to
someone they're like great we have an
opening in
two months and you're like well i need
it now so this you can communicate in
under
48 hours um there's a broad range of
expertise
which may not be locally available in
other areas maybe you want to
um you know talk to someone about
addiction or trauma
or breakups or anxiety whereas or the
old days
or the good old when we work the land
you log into your account anytime and
send a message to your counselor
you know their traditional therapy
drives me nuts because it's sort of like
i need to talk now i can't wait till
tomorrow yeah i'm sobbing in my car
it's like tinder for a therapist it kind
of is
you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses you can schedule weekly video
or phone sessions you'll never have to
sit in an uncomfortable waiting room
with that stupid zen garden with the
little pebbles in the sand and the rocks
you have to like
run into people you work with in the
waiting room betterhelp.com
visit their website read their
testimonials more affordable than
traditional offline counseling
and financial aid is available i love
this company it is such a game changer
do you want to read the logistics part
so i don't get it wrong
visit betterhelp.com whitney that's
better
help help and join over a
million people taking charge of their
mental health with the help of an
experienced professional
in fact so many people have been using
better health that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
i'm available
oh no special offer for good for you
listeners to get 10 percent off your
first month at betterhelp.com
whitney andrew yang it's
it's a it's a superhero crossover event
whitney cummings andrew yang together at
last
and we were just talking like i feel
like i've known whitney for years
because she worked with a close friend
of mine
uh and i've been a huge fan so thank you
this conversation feels long overdue
long overdue and i've been such a fan
ever since um you know i've obviously
read your books but
i heard you on rogan and i got to be
honest with you andrew i grew up in
washington dc
i grew up around politicians i'm sort of
born very cynical about politicians
hearing you on joe rogan with such a
breath of fresh air
the fact that a someone running for
president could even talk for three
hours without
you know seeming like they're full of
shit or disingenuous like i just
i am such a big fan of yours and oh
thank you that was the runner-up for
my slogan andrew yang not full of shit
well i think we're dealing with like
peak cynicism right now when it comes to
politics wouldn't you agree yeah the
fact that you
grew up in dc uh dc is a very
institutional town
and i feel like and this is hopefully
not anything that controversial but i
felt feel like you went to
a school that also is kind of stealth
institutional in the form of pen
like it's very practical but they all
become bankers and consultants
yeah i just get discouraged because it's
like and you know i don't
follow politics super closely because it
ends up depressing me and i get too
adrenalized and addicted to it it's
almost like a
like a sport it's i can get depressed
but people like you
have re-energized me and make me feel
hopeful and positive about the future
but when you start learning like
you know how campaigns are run how much
money's involved it makes you start to
feel hopeless and helpless
well what's fun whitney is uh i ran for
president and learned a lot and now i'm
starting to figure out
just how fucked up the system is and how
to unfuck it up
uh so one of my new that's gonna be your
next presidential slogan unfuck
america well hopefully you know where
uh we end up getting trump out and then
there's less of a sense that we're we're
all
uh feeling now but the problems in our
system
are structural in terms of the
incentives that legislators have and the
corporate interest in the rest of it
which i think most people
know something about but one thing
people do not know about is there's this
entire professional consultant class
that wraps itself around any candidate
and those incentives are also not
positive
uh so my goal right now is to figure out
everything i've seen in terms of how the
software of our political system
is leading us awry and that's one of the
reasons why people like you very very
smart
engaged people have washed their hands
of politics
it's not irrational to wash your hands
of politics because it's so infuriating
and everything seems so ineffective
one of the big fears i have is that
politics has become this
uh drama of characters rising and
falling but none of the real problems
get solved
right right right right and the problems
are
monumental i like i was concerned about
them even before the pandemic
and now they're worse than
most people even realize i'm genuinely
uh terrified for what happens if we
don't
do something very differently in the
next number of uh
terrified about um we'll talk about you
know automation in a second but
terrified for the environment for
mass riots like what is the main thing
you're afraid of
i'm afraid that the way of life for
millions
tens of millions of americans is
disintegrating in real time
and we put a bit of a stopper in that
through
the enhanced unemployment benefits and
the other stimulus programs that went
through the end of july but then they
ended
and right now we're talking in august
like the deterioration
in august is real time i'm friends with
a guy who runs a company that processes
all of the financial information for
over 2 million gig
and contract workers so in other words
he's got like a dashboard
of the financial situations of millions
of americans and he can see it in real
time
and he told me that he can see he saw
what happened when
the jobs got lost in
the spring but their incomes stayed
okay because of the unemployment
benefits and then it hit august and then
he said it's all
uh crashing down right now and the
number of
temp gig and jobs uh temp gig and
contract jobs that are available
on this you know millions of jobs
platform
has gone down by something like 60
percent
um and so if you can imagine millions of
americans who were cobbling together
lives through uh taskrabbit
uber uh like catering
uh you know anything where you know that
people do
contract work and that can be all the
way up to paralegals and accountants and
their contract lawyers like all of that
work
is disappearing yeah and then you
imagine what's happening
in those households but also in those
human beings yes
if you get that sense of scarcity it
starts to really
uh screw you up um
and can i just not to interrupt but um
in one of your books and also on rogan
you mentioned that our iq goes down by
13 points
when we can't pay our bills what
actually neurologically happens to our
brains when we're worried about money
we get dumber we start making less
um uh uh we start making worse decisions
for ourselves our judgment gets clouded
yeah we become more subject to really
nasty negative impulses which can be
self-destructive very often and that's
one of the things that i believe is
happening right now whitney is that
most of us when things start going
poorly like we're
the we're going to be we and the people
in our immediate vicinity are going to
be the first to know about it
you know what i mean like it's not
necessarily that you're going to go out
to the streets or do something
but you're going to start treating
yourself poorly you're going to start
treating the people in your lives poorly
uh the the mental health crisis yeah
predates
the pandemic but i've got two young kids
in the house
and uh i'm sure they're better situated
than
most american children and they are not
exactly flourishing in this time
you know you look around and you just
imagine that playing out
around the country so so those are the
things that terrify me is like
you're watching real time disintegration
um and then you have this political
system that is not connected
to that uh because of some of the
problems that
uh that i've discovered relatively
recently um they existed
but it's like oh you know i'm gonna run
for president and see what the heck is
going on here
uh so there's a disconnect there there's
a disconnect in the media
uh because the folks who do the
reporting uh
tend to live in and work in certain
environments and a lot of their work can
be
digital so that you're seeing
the glimpses of it uh in the food lines
and the rest of it
but the the true nature of it's still uh
massively unreported
can i ask you though real quick again
we're like a comedy podcast
it's called good for you we try to get
people as much information as possible
in a way that's
you know fun with some levity you know
because i think something you're so good
at is using humor so that people
actually
you know are able to process what you're
saying some of this stuff is so
depressing and bleak that
we shut down you know i find myself i go
onto a news site and i just like
you know i just don't have the emotional
bandwidth to process everything that's
that's also very very reasonable and
rational like you know right now
and that that's the tough part of this
is like i i tell everyone just like look
just take care of yourself
and a lot of times taking care of
yourself i mean turning shit off yeah
yeah and then but then you're
misinformed so it's this nightmare but
i'm gonna be really honest like you know
the new news media is really bothersome
to me
you know when i you know i don't talk
about my you know personal politics too
much i think it's
most of them are pretty obvious but you
know when i turn on a
network like cnn and i see the um
you know the news anchors rolling their
eyes and sighing and clearly having a
vendetta and clear
i just it shuts me down a little bit
because like i grew up in washington dc
there was the washington post i read it
every single morning and there was the
news
and then there was op-ed and there was a
difference between facts and opinions
now i never feel like i'm getting facts
i feel like i'm always getting opinions
and even though i agree with the people
that i'm watching for the most part i al
the way it's being delivered to me
sometimes just feels so glib
and emotional that it's hard for me to
feel like i'm getting accurate
information or it just sort of
turns me off it makes me feel like it's
a gossip session or something
you and i are just old enough to
remember a time when there were only
three tv networks
a few anchors to said pretty much the
same thing and there was like 30 minutes
of news a day
who knows if that was accurate back then
to be honest yeah a lot was well you
know what i mean but but it was like we
also read history books that said
columbus discovered america so
we were probably lied to it just seemed
like less of a lie
or it seemed more uh
more fact driven and less personality
driven yes that was part of it
it's like they they almost found the
most boring people
just speaking of automation they were
just robots that were just like reading
from a teleprompter
yeah the same voice being like today
you know and then it's morphed into this
other thing and one of the things i
called out recently
um on twitter you know and ended up with
like a in a in like a bit of a back and
forth with some characters is the media
right now is broken
yes i agree and and the fact that
someone like you
um has picked up the facts like look
like this stuff started to turn me off
because
uh it seems like we're all just uh
taking a
point of view and driving our point of
view and then each
news source has become something of a
new silo
where even if i agree with you it
bothers me
yeah where they're reinforcing certain
perspectives
and priorities and values um over and
over again and what's happened whitney
is they found that that's better for
their business
and right now all of their incentives
are around driving audience particularly
in a time when
you decimate let's call it a thousand
plus local newspapers which you've done
and then you have these cable networks
that you know are are very driven by
ratings that have a format and clickbait
and getting us to be emotional and
getting us to get adrenaline i mean i
think they know they're drug dealers at
this point i think they understand the
science you know
um rogan rogan and i were just talking
about that book irresistible about i
mean they know
that when they put an emotional word or
say
you know trump slammed like they use
these words that really adrenalize us
and get us to click
and it's really scary to think that they
sort of know what they're doing
it feeds off of conflict and
when i was running i tried i tried not
to
to get engaged with like the you know
trump tweet of the day
because i was like this is so dumb like
this is playing into his
hands and this is not the point and
there's like deeper
problems but that is the nature of our
news media and there was a
producer who recently left msnbc and
just called out and said look
i don't know if you saw the story ariana
pakari um she said look
the journalists are not bad people but
the system is driving
very very bad decisions yeah yeah and
and
and she said we get better ratings when
we talk about trump
so yeah we just talk about it yeah and
and we're theoretically
in opposition to trump but it turns out
that when we're making production
decisions
we lead with trump all the time because
and then it ends up in
inflaming certain emotional reactions
among people
uh so that that's the that's one of the
big concerns
and what's happening to our media is a
is a
an emblem of what's going wrong
generally
and i could even apply it to the
entertainment business that that you're
a part of
which is essentially the market drives
everything now
like if it makes money then that's what
we're going to do yeah
and yeah and one of the things i said on
the trail is if you have money on one
side and people on the other who's going
to win
money and then they think about it for a
second they're like
i mean neil postman there's an amazing
book that neil postman wrote i believe
in the 20s called amusing ourselves
i'm sorry in the 50s amusing ourselves
to death and i mean how
the way even when i you know turn on
news networks and there's an eagle flies
by and it's like
it looks like a marvel movie i mean the
news is now you know news and
entertainment are really merging in a
very post-modern
way um that's very surreal to watch but
you know i never thought i'd say this
but i i i would really love to just read
some boring news
with you know and also and i want to
talk to you about this because
i know you're working on something about
um getting paid for our data which is
fascinating to me and i would love to
get into it our attention spans now
are so short as well like i i see this
as being such an
um epidemic moving forward in terms of
our ability to
uh process information and gather the
information we need to make good
decisions as
voters and as americans which is like by
the time i read two sentences there's
like an ad pops up from a pair of shoes
that i put my cart two weeks ago
like you know i i feel like people talk
about the assault on democracy the bots
and the facebook
russian bots and all that too but also
just this assault on our attention
and the fact you know like what can we
do to protect ourselves from that and
where do you get your news
well it's one reason why podcasts were
so good for me
and that broken podcast in particular
yeah uh and it's one reason why
cable news was not a great format for me
because if you sit down and have
uh a five minute tv
hit with five questions and there's a
rhythm be like andrew like what do you
think about this
you know why are you doing this and
there's always like also
baked into those media interviews for
much or most of my campaign was a lot of
skepticism was
like do you really think you could win
stuff like that
but honestly let me tell you yeah i mean
the way that you handled that on rogan
was just so endearing and charming and
authentic and like yeah
i do you know we just saw something
pretty wild happen in you know
2016 that we never thought could happen
so why not
yeah and and it was fun surprising a lot
of folks because if you lined up 100 dc
pundits uh you know in in 2018 or 2019
and said
you know like is andrew yaring going to
outlast like a bunch of these senators
or governors or whatever
like you would have gotten zero takers
and so that the fact that we showed that
conventional wisdom is failing
um i'm very very proud of and thank
everyone who supported me are you gonna
run again
everyone's asking me to ask you that i'm
just going to keep trying to drive
forward
the solutions that i think we need as a
country and
i would 100 run again if i thought that
was the most effective
way to to advance some of these
solutions
uh right now universal basic income uh
now a majority of the country agrees
that we should do it wait so just
for those that don't i'm sure everyone
listening does but the fact that you
brought up universal basic income
people were like that we couldn't even
compute for a lot of people and now it's
just
happened does that bother you at all oh
i'm thrilled yeah the majority of
americans are now watching
what's your idea so it seems like you i
mean you're so genuine
it's like you just wanted it to happen
regardless of who did it you know
oh very much so i don't really love a
lot of
the uh politics stuff yeah i think that
you guys
sense that about me um and the behaviors
necessary to be a successful politician
are either unrelated or negatively
correlated with
yeah with the folks that you'd actually
want
why what is people's problem with this
idea
i'm just gonna be the joe blow and ask a
dumb question like
a thousand dollars that's a lot of money
for a month for people that can change a
lot of people's lives and i think a lot
of the people that talk about it
on the news or whatever it's just not a
lot of money to them so they don't think
it's necessarily a good idea but it's
like to
most people that can really change your
life that would be a game changer for
tens of millions but the people talking
about on television
because that's a small amount of money
to them
you know it's like it's like baked into
the the people's point of views that are
actually talking about it is that when
only rich people are talking about
something
that uh affects non-rich people they're
just way too biased to even understand
how valuable it is
yeah i i had that conversation a number
of times over there where
i was like yeah you do realize a
thousand dollars would actually be very
good and joe rogan's a good friend of
mine when he's like a thousand bucks is
that really going to change someone's
life i'm like yes joe
i know that's not a lot of money to you
but like i have family members
that that would completely transform
their lives
and also as you said just make them
sleep better operate better function
better you said iq goes down by 13
points when you're worried about paying
your bills like
imagine how much that would change just
the you know
the vibe of our country just sort of
like or imagine
increasing the collective iq of the
united states of america by 13 points
which is one standard
maybe people would stop you'd totally do
it maybe kids would stop eating tide
pods
it might actually be like oh you know
what if i don't
[Laughter]
can i just bring up that the democrats
or the left
you know i hate saying any of those
words it feels like teams at this point
you know it feels like
you know cowboys versus raptors or
something but
i do feel like and tell me if i'm wrong
the left puts their candidates through a
purity test
that is unproductive and in fight in a
way that i don't
see the right doing am i making that up
that's accurate and correct i believe
uh and uh it's
not a good thing i don't you know i
think it's unproductive you know and one
of the things i'm really proud of
whitney is that
i think people started to understand
what i was about over time
uh and uh realized that
you know i'm trying to help um and i'm
just using different
ideas than you've heard from other
people who are trying to help
be very good yeah but it seems like a
lot of the
the um uh most the most
pressure that the left gets is from
other leftist candidates it's like
really
i mean when i see people like i don't
know but like what about that vote from
22 years ago it's like dude shut
up you know i remember i heard once
um uh democrats have to fall in love
republicans fall in line
yeah and no one's perfect
and there is this strange standard that
we try and hold
uh political figures too particularly on
the left
where we expect you to be super humanly
uh clean cut positive squeaky clean
uh et cetera et cetera
and i think it
ends up resulting in a conversation that
doesn't speak to a lot of americans yeah
yeah and we're also just addicted to
outrage in a way that i just feel like
we really need to you know bring to
light and
per that can i just ask how important is
twitter
in terms of the decisions that you make
comedians were always trying to figure
out
uh am i getting cancelled like how many
tweets
means you're getting canceled how many
tweets means you need to make an apology
i'm just so curious for politicians
because i think we all are so desperate
to be heard we're all so desperate to
make a change
you know sometimes people vote in a way
with their tweets like everyone just
wants to
be heard um so badly how much of an
impact does twitter have on the
decisions that you made when you were
running and that you make on a daily
basis
in terms of feedback i've
uh spent a lot of time on twitter over
the last a couple of years
and i started my campaign with perhaps 5
000 followers
and now um now it's like 1.6 million so
i i have like this
relationship with twitter where it was
just me and freaking nobody listening
and then when folks started um
uh responding to me or following me they
were all
yang gang frank gang because no one else
cared about what i was saying uh and so
i ended up with this
group of people that was very
like-minded frankly like-minded to
to you as well um that we're tired of
politics as usual and wanted to talk
about
different ways we can solve our problems
and bring people together
and stop the polarization and
demonization and that that's happening
um and so i wound up with this
incredible
community of folks around me on twitter
and then when i got big enough
when people started objecting to various
things that i said or did
uh there were yangyang being like uh you
know no
like shut up and then i was just like oh
this is very very positive
and the young guy really you're the only
person that's ever had a positive
experience on twitter by the way
testament to your fans well i really do
appreciate the heck out of them and the
yang gang
was so vital to my campaign gaining any
traction because what would happen was
uh reporters would ignore me and then
all these people on twitter would be
like hey why didn't you include yangon
story yeah
the yang yang was also very very
positive generally yes
they because we have a vibe of
uh not being jerks and that's the thing
that
uh journalists actually said to me
numerous times where like your people
are the most courteous i agree calm
rational
kind yeah yeah so so i've had a very
unusual twitter experience
um and not to say there isn't some
negativity because you know you get to a
certain
point and then people uh start trying to
throw rocks occasionally
um but i'm personally above average at
laughing off like rocks that are thrown
at me uh
you know and i had a note on my phone at
one point during the campaign
which is just remember that to the vast
majority of americans you're just the
magical asian man who wants to give
everyone money
because then when someone was like
taking aim at something i said to some
group i'd be like just remember
that to the vast majority of americans
you were just
but i am just very curious in terms of
like how much of
our um digital
footprint matters to politicians when
we're is it
useless for us to tweet is it helpful
for us to tweet
like what how much of an impact are our
voices having
when people do tweet just for everybody
listening that are trying to find
ways that democracy is going to evolve
you know how can we
exercise um our rights
as a democracy on a daily basis now
since it seems to be crumbling and
and atrophying in other places like is
is twitter something that makes an
impact
uh if we don't like something or is it
something that
you know is it sort of our job as
americans to
speak on twitter every day because i
think some of us feel helpless some of
us feels like it's just an echo
chamber it is certainly no one's job to
speak on twitter every day
yeah so so i'm the math guy
approximately 21
of americans have a twitter account and
of them many of them are inactive
i think two percent of them generate 80
of the
tweets yeah so so you have to know
you're looking at
like a very very distinct subset and
slice of people
and when i was marching around iowa new
hampshire the vast majority of people i
saw on the trail in the cafe or the
union hall
were not on twitter right interesting
also look who our nominee is like joe
biden um
is our nominee and i don't think he was
rocking out twitter
on the regular to the people of south
carolina like that wasn't the way that
went down
so uh so what is it good for uh
it is good for uh community building
yeah uh in some cases
uh it's good for making people feel like
they can connect with you and know you
and it's very very good
for driving media narratives uh because
if you look at
i'm gonna say like 95 percent of major
journalists
are on twitter do pay attention to it uh
and you can see stories getting driven
from
twitter obviously i mean donald trump
discovered this discovered it like
you know in 2016 and then uh rammed it
all down our throats
um but for me too i started with this
modest following and whitney the first
time i tweeted something and it was it
popped up on cable news it like blew my
mind
i was like
again like not having any audience so
the fact that so what it was was it was
a picture of a waffle house
and it just said back in the south
because i was back you know i was back
in south carolina i just thought this
would be like you know a random thing
and then it just like popped up on the
uh
on cnn and i was like they just took my
ring
from a waffle house and they didn't like
delve into it for you know five minutes
but they just like being like andrew
yang on the trail
and so um and so that and keep in mind i
was running for president and so i was
like ooh
like that's a way i can drive uh
attention and
and conversation and in my case my
campaign ended up being driven by a lot
of
uh internet friendly content um and and
i was trying to compete so like i leaned
into it
so so those are things that twitter can
be very effective at is driving media
narratives
uh and cultural commentary
um but for reaching the vast majority of
the electorate
it is uh not going to be your first tool
oh that's very interesting um i
i feel like one weird thing we have in
common is we're both obsessed with
talking about robots
um my last stand-up special i had a
robot in it and
you know i a companion robot um and
i just you know got so obsessed with the
fact that this is so close
and nobody's talking about it and uh i
don't
understand why it's not covered more um
the question is you've talked so much
about how automation is going to take
jobs is there ever a scenario where
they're going to create jobs that are
safer
like in customer service for the
automation tools like is there anything
to look forward to in that area
there is something to look forward to if
we make it something positive happen
so that the problem right now is that
and i've run companies so
like everything about the companies is
trying to optimize and maximize the
bottom line
uh and so if i can find a way to
get rid of your job and replace you with
software or robot or ai or whatever it
is i'm going to do it like 100 times out
of 100.
uh and so our only path out is to start
creating incentives for us to do
different types of things that are not
robot competitive now are there's are
there certain contexts where robots are
going to do things that we don't want
any human doing
like yeah so we could look forward to
that it'd be like you can imagine
something really
shitty that people are doing right now
that like a robot will do
um and so on and we should be
celebrating i'll give you an example
that you know it's from like the
the campaign that's very pressing uh
if you had self-driving trucks that
would be tremendously disruptive
to our labor force because you have over
three million truckers that's right
but but trucking is very very bad for a
person's physical well-being over time
like you're sitting in one place you're
isolated or you know like yeah not like
the i mean the the health problems
among uh truckers are rampant
uh endemic and so you can imagine an
alternative world where we're like
celebrating the liberation of truckers
yeah cause like
great news your truck and drive itself
like but you're gonna end up with riots
because they're like
what are you talking about it's like my
livelihood and my existence
and i think it's important for those of
you that um you know didn't hear the
rogan podcast you talking about
you know the riots like as you said this
has happened before in the first
industrial revolution there were riots
this is possible we're seeing it through
the pandemic too
because very reasonable companies are
automating things away because
it's just not it's now it's just better
with the bottom line it's better from a
public health standpoint if you're a
consumer you like it more
you go in before and you might have
thought the the robot in walmart was
creepy before but now you're like yeah
you know
less human interaction like it it's
weird
[Laughter]
it doesn't have to wear a mask don't
have to worry about having coven
yeah so the the robots are
uh here to stay and it's picking up
steam there was a story about how even a
meatpacking
factory was replacing their processing
workers with robots because
the the fear was that if you have too
many workers in the meat
processing plant they might get coveted
and infect each other so it's like let's
just replace them with robots
uh so the pandemic could even accelerate
this the robots seem like an even better
idea
right it's an even better idea i think
there was a major
study that asked hey are you increasing
your investment in automation because of
the pandemic
and about half companies said yes wow
wow not to mention if you know it's
retail or restaurants closing stores and
you know the
places that would need human beings in
the first place okay are we
are we rolling yeah
you're listening to this and not
watching it on youtube
shame on you you're about to miss me
but also keep listening to it don't
don't like stop
quip is a toothpaste benton you can see
all the clips
no i'm not a toothbrush they also make
it too they make a toothpaste too i'm
fully obsessed everybody asks me how i
clean these giant ass horse teeth
i am so obsessed with this toothpaste
look how cool it is it looks so in the
future
beautiful in your bathroom and it sits
up straight you know how tooth
paste mostly lie on their side and then
all like goose out i'm about to show you
something for those of you that can't
see it benton will describe it
when you open the cap there's no goo
everywhere she's opening a cap that
um of the quipped toothpaste is mostly
clean
it is i know i just squirted a little
bit out and look how you never have to
squeeze the top because it sits up right
and it's just right there it's always
the bottom you're not guys gravity
you're not like i'm just saying you're
not like fighting with this toothpaste
tube and like
like it's not all nasty and gross it's
just the first thing i do in the morning
is i brush my teeth and i want
i don't want it to be a hassle it sets
the tone for my entire day
you know what you're describing what
those ads where white people just like
fumble and throw things around and like
infomercials that you and your
toothpaste okay i don't know what that
means but
thank you um and then the toothbrush is
so sexy i don't know if i'm allowed to
say this can you read the copy to make
sure what i'm saying listen
when's the last time you got rewarded
for brushing your teeth look how
beautiful
this is it goes into this glass
container it almost looks like
like an old cool chemistry yeah i love
that you kept your case too oh my god
so you like beauty and the beast oh i'm
obsessed with it it's like
christmas every morning i love that this
right here sticks to
mirrors and like showers yes you can put
i love it on a mirror
like put it up in your shower poo
brushes their teeth in the shower
that's a very specific type of person
you're a psychopath i brush my teeth in
the shower and also not in the shower
okay i have two toothbrushes okay can
you believe two equips
um uh the master of quips literally and
figuratively bent and ray
listen when's the last time you got
rewarded for brushing your teeth also
sorry look at the base of this it's
almost like a beautiful rose gold is
this gorgeous it literally is
gorgeous toothbrush like honestly this
is this sexiest toothbrush it makes me
feel so
fancy in the morning when i use it i
know i have the all bla
matte black one it feels like a blade
runner it's like the toothbrush they
used in blade runner i turned it on can
you guys hear it
z can you hear it well you know what i'm
gonna say no which i like i don't like
that when you're in the morning waking
up
okay we have to get to the details at
some point but i just want you guys to
understand why i've been asking you
when's the last time you got rewarded
for brushing your teeth
uh uh it's a great question i mean i
guess
just because i have to wear a mask all
the time and i don't have to spell bad
breath so every time i put on my mask
well with quipp's new smart electric
toothbrush good habits can bring you
great pork
perks porks great perks like free
products gift cards and more
oh nice track when and how well you
brush get tips and coaching on how
to improve your habits which i actually
need because my dentist recently told me
i don't reach back far enough that's a
different conversation
redeem for rewards free products gift
cards and discounts from quip
and partners if you already have equip
you can upgrade it with a spar
smart motor and keep the features you
know and love sensitive sonic vibrations
i just showed you that
a two minute timer with 30 second pulses
for guided
clean that's what it does it has these
little pulses so you don't have to go
like did i brush too much over here like
you just
outsource that decision to someone else
you see people to brush their teeth and
just like throw them right and you're
like that wasn't brushing
it's too fast and too much and you did
too much in the wrong place and not
enough
in the right place breaking down those
gums mint or watermelon toothpaste
for adults watermelon i'm obsessed i
know it's so good it's
so it's like delicious it's yeah you
don't eat it don't eat i want to
we just lost this sponsor anti-cavity
ingredients for strong
healthy teeth floss that expands to
clean and comes in a refillable
dispenser to reduce waste which is my
biggest problem with floss is it's just
like so much
so bad for the environment eco-friendly
solar battery charger to
power your quip with sunshine how uh
i am so proud to be involved with this
company
that was a sincere statement i know i
love them and
you can get the brush head the
toothpaste the floss refills all
delivered
for five dollars to your door wow wow
that's crazy slim white light weight
sleek with no wires no bulky charger to
weigh
you down join over five million mouths
who already use quip save hundreds
compared to other bluetooth
brushes where you get a quip smart brush
for just 45
join the revolution get into the future
stop with that old nasty moldy crusty
ass brush you've been using you're
embarrassing yourself
honestly if you're a guy i'm just going
to be straight with you get equip and
put it in your
dating app main photo and your life will
change
to the tooth i'm joking if i was on a
dating app and i saw a guy just holding
a quip
i just like he the dentist yep oh just
be like you make great decisions like i
know everything i need to know about you
you're modern you have your am i allowed
to curse in these
you have your crap together you have
your priorities straight like you're
just it would be
it's the opposite of a red flag start
getting rewards for brushing your teeth
today you get rewards
for brushing your teeth and go to get
quip.com whitney right now get your
first refill
free i'm starting to stutter so why
don't you go that's your first refill
free
and quit at no that's your first refill
free at
get quip dot com slash whitney spelled
g e g-e-t-q-u-i-p dot com slash whitney
quip better oral health made simple and
rewarding
ernest ernest lee
ernest ernest you know what
it's so cool that we're talking about
earnest which helps with student loans
because a big part of andrew yang's
platform which he's been talking about a
lot is about reducing
debt for students and just how
ridiculously expensive
um college is and a big part of my
platform is annoying all the calls they
give me
[Laughter]
i was like you knew you weren't getting
that when you gave it to me student
loans
are so emotionally crippling just
knowing they're following you around
just
knowing no matter how hard you work
you're still gonna have to give
a part of your paycheck to a school from
eight years ago
you know it's just so crazy the fact
that we allow 19 year olds to make that
decision
i know and you have no idea what you're
signing up for student loans
and refinancing them with earnest could
save you money or
lower your monthly payment and it only
takes two minutes to
check your rate online in this podcast
with andrew
we've probably already said this when
you're worried about money your iq goes
down
12 and that's my problem
which is like when you're preoccupied
with money and scared
of of money it's just hard to make good
decisions so this is really really
worth looking into if you have the sort
of cloud of student loans hanging over
your head if you're still paying the
same rate you were paying when you
graduated the odds are you could reduce
your monthly payment
and save majorly if you've already
refinanced
today's low rate environment most people
can actually
refinance again in earnest is the
easiest way to refinance your student
loans saving you time saving you money
checking your rate they make it fast
they make it easy uh
it takes two minutes you'll get your
personalized rate estimate without
affecting your credit score that is
really the most important because
sometimes when you go and look up
refinancing it affects your credit score
sneaky they'll do anything to ruin your
credit god they will do anything
anything to ruin your credit oh you want
to shop at victoria's secret i don't
think so
now you're homeless oh you just googled
the new cardi b
song your credit goes down yeah if you
qualify earnest
offers customizable loans and no fees
you can even combine
private and federal loans that sounds
super complicated but they make it easy
so that you have one
single monthly payment that is so
awesome if you've already financed a
loan
no prob lemo you can still be edible to
lower your interest rate
and the internet loves earnest's
customer service they are rated 9.4
out of 10 on trust pilots you'll always
get the support you need that's
that's a big deal you have to call
someone and talk about your money or
something like that oh so straight
or like a bill place like and the person
has like an attitude
nothing worse oh yeah i'm already
frustrated i'm already anxious like
obviously
you know so that is really cool that
they're that's amazing so on top of it
start saving today our listeners
i want to call the customer service just
to like just say thank you so much i
just want to like talk what are you up
to just want to say hi you guys sound
awesome like i'm working
no but i just you guys are rated so
highly on trust pilot like do you want
to hang out
basically yeah did it be friends start
saving today our listeners get a hundred
dollar cash bonus
brief that is truly awesome when you
refinance a student loan at earnest.com
whitney that's a hundred dollar cash
bonus when you refinance a student loan
at earnest.com
whitney go to earnest.com whitney today
earnest like
terms and conditions apply like ernest
goes to jail
um i'm curious if you uh uh
talk much about the ethical uh
implication of robots if
like why aren't laws starting to be made
around this stuff like i feel like we're
laws
i just feel like we are so behind
because i got a robot built for my last
special
and i now know how many companion robots
are being purchased a lot of people that
buy them
keep them secret you might not know
about them but it's so much uh
bigger than we think it is and it's so
much closer if not
uh it's already here like why is it
because lawmakers i'm just gonna be dumb
for a second is it because they're just
old like why
it's not dumb at all yeah so that
yes i mean there are a number of reasons
but our government
is decades behind on technology issues
which includes robots and they don't
understand
i've been to the dmv i noticed or
if you just take your average congress
person
like what is their life they shuttle
between their district
and dc you've spent time in dc so it's
not exactly like this tech hub
no no no no they they pride themselves
on the charm of like colonial
architecture
it's like this doesn't feel like we're
just like it's the the laws feel as
archaic
as the architecture of the city you're
like this feels does not feel modern
yeah a congressman said that to me said
that the halls of congress just reminded
him of imperial rome just to say like
look nothing's going to change
yeah exactly not all the marvel columns
if the laws are at all
as old as these buildings we have a
problem
one of my dreams uh it'd be very hard to
execute so i have to figure it out um
but
if you're trying to change the culture
of a place changing the physical
environment is a great way to go
so i'm imagining can you imagine if
congress met
in like uh like one of those modern
office buildings yes
you know what i mean like or or like a
um
not to be extreme because they're there
but like even one of these like silicon
valley type slick
class and uh you'd go in there and you'd
feel like you were part of the future
and then someone's like yeah you should
probably make a rule about
freaking ai this is why it's so you know
and i've been talking about this a lot
in my stand up before the pandemic
happened in my you know tour guide
council but you're talking a lot about
getting paid for your data
and i've heard you say that data is like
the new oil
right and it's i would love to hear your
take on this i would love to hear
um share this with everybody it's so
important but i look at the lawmakers
and i'm like
we can't have a conversation with data
with these people they're still probably
on aol
they're probably on sbcglobal.net like
these people
don't have an alexa these people
probably aren't even thinking about this
it doesn't affect them or bother them
they're just that this is the the
problem is that
you have legislators who don't have
incentives around solving problems
they have incentives around raising
money avoiding controversy
uh making sure they don't get challenged
by someone meaningful their district i
mean that's really
that's that's their the job seeking uh
one thing i'm for which would change
things dramatically is term limits
because then your incentive is to get
there and solve problems and then
leave you're gonna leave no matter what
so when i was on the campaign trail i
said
look here's how we get term limits
passed term limits for everyone but
current lawmakers are exempt
that way you can pass term limits and
then being like
fucking i'm grandfathered in yeah yeah
yeah yeah we're not affecting you
we're not taking bread don't worry about
it you could be here until they pry
your seed out of your you know clammy
dead hands
but but the person after you and they
were like
hey they couldn't even hear you so they
didn't even know what you were pitching
they were like we don't
can't the hearing aid's broken so i i
joked with folks i was like
uh if you could get them on board if
they were all grandfathered in they'd be
like we do this for the country
themselves would be like oh so so that's
the kind of structural change you would
need to make to
change the incentives to make it so that
their job is to try and get something
done and then get out and know they're
not going to have
careers that are that span decades yeah
they just have this tenure
where they never have to modernize or
update their own software in their brain
yeah so that the challenge
around data is similar to this where
uh they don't understand um they're 25
years behind
on technology they got rid of the office
that assessed technology in 1995 so
they've had
advice yeah i know it it seems
fucking ridiculous crazy so so there
used to be something called the office
of technology assessment that advised
uh our legislators on technology issues
very reasonable
uh had a relatively modest budget of
let's call it you know like 20 or 30
million
um and then they got rid of it in 95 as
a cost-saving measure
and now the only source of technology
advice for legislators is the technology
companies
who guess what they're like oh jesus
god so and then you have the average age
of the legislators and then you have an
incentive structure around them
um not having to solve problems and then
you have
the fact that technology is not
something that most of them understand i
think the average age of a legislator 62
give you a sense of um like the
generational
gap uh so am i ageist
in thinking like how can someone that
that age
solve a data mining issue uh
yeah there are like a couple of senators
who get it mark warner of virginia is
like a tech type i really like right
right yeah there's some tech around
tyson's corner right
in virginia yeah yes yes exactly you got
it but
uh but most of them don't understand it
at all so
what's happened and this actually goes
back to the data and media conversation
whitney and i'm so
freaking excited about trying to solve
for this so here's the deal
you go to facebook years ago and you set
up your account
and you're like okay it's free great and
then you you get everything's free
nothing's free
and then facebook's like i'm gonna like
sell advertisements to you
uh and then i'm gonna start tracking
everything you do and i'm just allowed
to advertise
they can target you more efficiently and
so at this point
uh the selling and reselling of our data
now generates hundreds of billions of
dollars a year
and so when you talk about it's like oh
it's free it's like actually at this
point
facebook is generating uh tens of
billions of dollars
a year largely off of micro targeting
us in various ways and they say if uh if
a product is free you're the product
right yeah so now where the product but
part of it
someone called it surveillance
capitalism which is a fairly good name
whoa
um so so we then become
like these rats in the maze and then
like you know getting pelted by digital
breadcrumbs
and then all of the folks who are in the
system then have incentive to try and
catch our attention
yeah in any way possible um which is
leading to an erosion of our mental
health and erosion of trust in each
other and erosion of the way we get
process information and changes
incentives the media companies
uh so it's all tied together and
the way to think about the contrast is
between youtube and netflix and not to
say that either
is perfect yeah but youtube is free
but you get there and then they pelt you
yep yep yep yep ad after
netflix you pay and they pelt you but
they put you in a much more like
like gentle way and if you don't watch
the particular thing like i don't care
and youtube also targets you in a way
that is
hurts your feelings they end up
targeting things to you
uh based on your google searches and
mine is always like betterhelp.com like
therapy i'm like easy
but the ads you get targeted have
something to do with what you've
searched right so it's always ends up
yeah yeah yeah
youtube's never engagement rings for me
no one's ever trying to target that
that's part of the selling and reselling
it's even creepier when you have like a
phone call or text conversation and then
they hit you with that ad you're like
whoa
yeah you're like it's raining out and
then you get a pop-up for an umbrella
and you're like where did that come from
so
you know and the devil's advocate this
is kind of what i was working on uh
before i wasn't allowed to perform
anymore because of the pandemic but like
we grew up at a time you know that was
very different because now everyone's
like they take your phone number and
they take your data it's like well when
i grew up there was a book full of
everyone's phone number and home address
it was called the phone book and they
would
throw it at your house okay would just
be like on everyone's patios like we
just you know
you know homeless people had they were
hanging from uh from phone booths our
data was everywhere right we would send
postcards which literally had our data
like you know facing out we didn't have
encrypted documents we would
fax our documents to a kinkos and our
encryption was like a cover page like
that was our security a piece of paper
you know so um why is it so important
that we think about this
and what would it actually look like if
we got paid for our data
so the idea would be that we have a data
bill of rights
where essentially you say to the
facebooks and google's
and they're the two biggest data
purveyors though there are hundreds of
other data brokers that are
lesser players in this industry
but you go to the facebooks and google's
of the world and say look my data is
mine
and you have to tell me what you're
doing with it you have to tell me if you
sell and resell it
right i can turn it off i can move it
with me yeah
and uh and if you do sell it i want to
cut because then at least i can
now now here's the thing most of us are
not interested in being our own data
cops because
we have lives yeah yeah yeah exactly
you don't necessarily want to be like
what's going on there and so
what you would do is you would end up
knighting an intermediary
and i actually formed an intermediary uh
called the data dividend project which
is like you can sign up at ddpforall.com
and we want to be your data cop and then
essentially say look we'll
figure out what's happening with your
data you can tell us generally what you
want to have happen
and then and if there's value then you
get it as opposed to right now
the tech company is running off with it
right so this is one possible approach
um a technologist named jaren lanier
called it like as
uh data intermediaries because
because we don't necessarily again want
to be our own data cops but
at this point it's essentially a
free-for-all
and there are various impacts and the
impact that i've been trying to pitch to
people is like look
if they're making 200 billion dollars a
year shouldn't we be getting some of
that off of your google searches and
yeah every time you sign up for
something or download an app or whatever
and i was
recording a podcast in west virginia
last year and
you know the people i was talking to
made a really good point which is that
the coal companies came in and mined all
our natural resources
and now you know the big tech companies
are coming in and mining our
data and it's just like it feels like
the you know same thing again
yeah and just like you ended up with
regulation saying can't dump that crap
in the river that's right like
in in this case it would be like can't
just sell and resell
our data willy-nilly and just pray upon
us right right
like you know sort of inputs into the
like the giant
machine uh and so this
you can see it as an economic argument
you can see it as a fundamental human
agency an autonomy
argument you can see it as a mental
health argument you can see it as a
democracy argument
but it's all crucial um
and the fact that we have let it go this
far is just a sign of the fact that our
government is way out to lunch
on these issues and they don't
understand what the heck is happening
now they're starting to examine the tech
companies more closely
around antitrust issues where they're
saying look some of the stuff's
anti-competitive
the most ridiculous thing was when
zuckerberg was like i i
you know they thought i'd be mean to
instagram if they didn't say yes to my
acquisition offer
yeah it was just like so the
anti-competitive stuff is like the first
thing they're looking at
but to me the data rights piece
is as or more important and
and one of the things that i want to do
uh
if joe and kamala win is to advance
these ideas and try and drag our
government
forward because we're not going to have
a functioning society or democracy
if we don't start giving ourselves more
control
over what's happening to our data colin
quinn did a special
about possibly splitting america into
two countries
i don't know if you heard of that sort
of idea does that just sound insane
where did he draw the new boundaries
that's a really good way to put it it's
like yeah yeah south northeast yeah
um you know people say like our
country's so divided our country's so
divided is
are we more divided than ever or is that
just something we say because it sounds
good
well most americans agree on most things
if you frame them
uh in a certain way i agree it's just
right it's just right now you have
uh this coded language that has led to
tribalism
and so and then you just gin us up
against each other uh pretty quickly
and i learned this on the trail
where i did not understand the coded
language thing
like i just presented uh arguments and
what i thought was english in numbers
[Laughter]
we should probably do something about
the fact that ai is coming and or the
rest of it it's a little too rational
sir can you please say something
irrational so that we'll listen
well here's where it got wild whitney is
that uh what i realized
was that my way of describing problems
and solving them
became their own uh
symbols yeah um and there was a real
need
for a different approach and uh happily
you know hundreds of thousands even
millions of americans got behind that
approach
um and it drew in a different set of
people and so what i've realized is that
you have these
different uh framing of the same issues
with these symbols and there are a lot
of structural incentives around trying
to get people
excited enough about these things to
dislike the other people
yeah yeah yeah yeah i just feel like
we're being pitted against each other in
a way where even someone that i
ostensibly like
should disagree with if i get in a room
with them for five minutes like we agree
on most things they're probably fine
yes like i actually really like you like
i tour all over the country it's
something that
you know i feel so grateful as a
comedian that i actually get to go out
into the world
and you know see people in these red
states blue states which are now just it
feels so
binary and i go out and i'm like we have
so much in common like you know people
come to my shows and
you know we talk afterwards and you'd
think we were differently aligned and
i'm like this just all feels
very um fabricated in order to
pit us against each other to create that
adrenaline that's going to make us click
and make us outraged
and that's what we have to put a stop to
because if we do that we can
uh find common ground and and i like
most people
i've been all victory sort of like a
comedian i guess yeah
you know it's like but i find most
people to be very very
uh very
good reasonable yeah reasonable
reasonable like i just feel like people
are way more reasonable than we all
think and we're
operating these generalizations now and
these polar opposites of like
everyone's this and the south is this
and the north is this and
you know it's just like um i guess we
also really have to look at our
neurology and the way that our
you know kind of brains are wired you
know it's what does it say about human
beings that we invented
robots that might eventually replace us
you know we do a lot of
irrational things well i will say
whitney we have
under invested in the integrity of our
society for
decades so to the extent that we don't
have as much in common with each other
we haven't really been staying in that
commonality
and i'll give you an example of
something that i thought would be
uh a very positive step is i propose an
american exchange program where
your senior year in high school you go
to another part of the country love it
your family
love it you just live and work there for
you know like uh like
six to eight weeks that's genius like
facebook friends with like
folks who had another when they go back
and be like hey i was
in arkansas and like people were fine
and friendly and like you know
nice to me and i lived with a family and
like their kid went somewhere yes
i love that it's not very expensive and
it's the kind of thing that
would build national integrity uh like
we're not investing in national
integrity
there there are agreements to be
circumstances that drove us towards it
for example let's say you had
you know a world war and then you know
like drafted people and
there was like this sense of common
purpose
uh and so it's one reason why
people are making calls to national
service uh
over this past number of months which i
agree with um and so my
american exchange program is supposed to
be some of the ingredients of that
now at this point because we're short
millions of jobs we should just be
finding ways to put people to work yeah
um particularly young people who are
going to
struggle to find a real path forward um
if you were to those opportunities if
your children said
dad i'll do whatever you say i'll go to
the college you want me to go to
or not go if you don't want me to i'll
take the clat like what would you want
your kids to major in
and what would you want them to do the
the problem with
whitney is that we've uh failed to adapt
our
educational system for what's going on
out there yeah so here's what's
happening right now
at large uh in the country and it's even
it's much much worse now
um so college has gotten uh two to three
times more expensive than it was since i
went
probably about twice as expensive as
when when you went yeah um
and what's happened was that colleges
have become
very large bureaucracies uh and
they raise their prices every year and
then if you're
unless you're a hollywood celebrity in
which case
you can pay to have your kid on the
canoe team or whatever
well i'm sure they they jack the price
up extra high for that person
so so the so the costs have gone up and
up and then families are like well no
choice but to pay but
incomes have not gone up uh and so then
they just took out
1.6 trillion plus in loans uh and and
just everyone thought well that's
appropriate because everyone's doing it
and then it turns out when your kid
graduates from college uh the
the salaries had not gone up and so
you've had this massive imbalance where
you've just built up this giant debt
pile
uh and people's professional prospects
have not
meaningfully changed so if you
say well what would i advise a young
person to do
like we need to try and make it so that
college doesn't break the bank for the
average
american family and then we need to try
and invest in non-college
routes primarily vocational schools
because we're can i ask you what that
means exactly what an example is
uh vocational school is pretty much
anything that after you come out you can
do something
yeah applicable knowledge you mean
yeah so uh you know it could be the
plumber mechanic um
uh hair stylist
you know like anything i need in that
milieu yeah uh
because right now we're way below the
rest of the developed
world in terms of the proportion of our
people that go through vocational
embarrassing embarrassing in the us it's
six percent of
high school grads who are in vocational
in germany it's
over 50 percent give you a sense uh and
so what we've done is we've
sold college college college to people
we've stigmatized anything that's not
college
we then made college crazy expensive yep
uh
only about a third of americans will
actually graduate from college
the college completion rate has gone
down the other half will have to go to
rehab afterwards because of
college and non-college paths
so those are the that's the structural
backdrop of what we've done
uh to really shaft a lot a lot of people
a lot of young people
so then if you line me up with like an
individual young person and say hey what
should this young person do
uh it depends upon that person's profile
uh i think that
for most people if they're in a position
to go to college it's a good thing
um if you're in that
top third of the population for whom
frankly like you know
it's it's appropriate um and then what
you'd study
there's like a message right now that
you should hire study
science technology engineering math
uh and the rest of it and those things
are helpful in that they
make you into a structured thinker and
will make you able to
frankly like interface with a lot of
these technological changes in a more
positive way
um but the proportion of people that are
going to be
employed in stem fields is still
relatively low
relative to the population so saying
everyone should learn to code is
bullshit and the fact is most people
don't particularly want to code
yes sounds very tedious yeah so going
around telling kids it's like hey
really get in there and like come sign
up they're like no i want to get girls
yeah yeah that's i hope my boys say that
so so um
so what i advise folks to do um is to
try and pursue something
that gives them a sense of adaptability
resilience
grit ability to work more with others
direction
and seek that out professionally too
where if you can
work with someone who will actually
give you the time of day where you know
you can get a sense as to
um how they do what they do like that
that sort of thing is the
best measure that's generally applicable
um another thing that's generally
applicable is to try and avoid
massive debt loads because like most
anything that's gonna
like throw that much debt on you is a
bad value prop
uh if you like coding in the rest of it
fantastic if you don't like you know
like they're gonna be many many roles
for folks who like people
uh and you know uh
because i i think we're doing people a
disservice when we're just trying to
um trying to turn them all into
engineers
we have so little time but i just want
to throw out it drives me
so insane that voting is on a tuesday it
drives me nuts
you talk about this so stupid it's
another anachronism
it was literally so that you could have
time to like take the wagon from your
it was that law was made when we were in
agrarian society sunday was church
monday
was a travel day and tuesday was voting
day what
i don't mean to be a conspiracy theorist
but why isn't this changing why isn't a
holiday why isn't it a weekend
it's because in america nothing
can change because it would be
un-american to change
but it's just like what like who's
stopping this there's there have been
bills to try to change it people have
tried and just failed
because there's a vested interest in
keeping it unfortunately voting has
become kind of politicized
yeah i was proposing a whole series of
reforms like we should make it a
national holiday
yes do you remember when the freaking
day off yes it uh
make it out on a tuesday yes give me the
national holidays
insanity saturday or a good day uh
yeah it's unfortunate because anything
around voting like there are certain
people that
uh think that making it harder to vote
is good for their
prospects you know and you're seeing it
now with this election
yeah it's so fascinating and and um
what a lot of people are asking me to
ask you about what's going on with the
mail right now
how worried should we be how paranoid
should we be is this election gonna get
postponed
what can we do what should we do how
freaked out should we be
i'm not as freaked out uh on the
postal service uh issue because and it
was very very helpful that
i i think that um to the extent that
there was
something afoot you know now a lot of
attention is being paid
um so thank you to the folks who who
were
uh on the spot um but from the numbers
standpoint
on the average christmas season uh the
post office moves like a couple billion
pieces
billion pieces of mail and so if you
look at the context of an election
like we should be able to get it done uh
you know within the current operational
uh resources of the post office
uh it's it's to me the central question
though
that people are asking and should ask is
that are we gonna be able to count votes
when we get results
if you have a dragged on election what
does that look like what does that mean
um so that stuff is very real and that
which we know is going to happen
regardless right
yeah so that that is very important um
but i don't think we should be afraid
that somehow like all the votes are
going to be
lost or you know you send the mail
because uh the mail actually in
a way is like a fairly a strong paper
trail
you know like unless you believe in it
to such an extent where you think
they're going to take
thousands and thousand envelopes and
like throw them in a dumpster somewhere
yeah which and you'd have to do that
like all over the country
uh in different places with like
different people like that yeah
you know the paper trail around the mail
is fairly strong um
and so i'm not as freaked out as others
that's a good point yeah yeah that's a
really good point i was like what are
they going to set it on fire and a
barrel
yeah okay now that i'm like thinking it
through i'm less panicked
yeah but it's great that we're attentive
to it and the fact that the president
was trying to undermine mail-in voting
um is just freaking bizarre
and nuts and the fact that we're at this
stage is
part of the dystopia that is america in
2020.
but you might run again last last last
last what was the most surprising thing
about running that you didn't expect
like a thing that was like oh i didn't
realize that was part of the process or
oh that was harder than i thought or
easier than i thought the most
surprising thing was the love whitney
oh really you know and
i mean you're part of it but not
everyone you got it not all not all the
people that run get that love
well i guess maybe that's why it was
such a surprise to me but you know
so so i'm
like i'm like a fairly uh
rational guy i think and so i was like
okay like let's run for president try
and solve these problems
uh and just some of the enthusiasm and
uh hope and optimism that i saw and
people who came to my events and wore
math hats and the rest of it was just so
incredibly touching
and it may be ridiculous to hear from
someone who was running for president
but like i was stunned every time like i
would go
someplace and be like well people are
actually here to see pretty exciting
and then that's because you're not a
malignant narcissist like most
politicians
and it's true to this day even uh
where and of course corvid is
complicated too but yeah because i've
been in the house an awful lot but you
know you go out and then someone's like
yay good i love you and i'm just like
really
universal and in a day where people want
any opportunity to hate anything or
criticize anything you are
see to be the most universally beloved
uh person and uh having you on it's just
it's been what a dream you're just
you're just a dream
and everything that um i hope for
my future children um you know and uh
it's so rare that there's a role model
out there anymore i mean i always say
kids just don't have role models and
you're one of the few that i mention
uh when i you and beyonce
oh that's so kind that's very elevated
company i don't think i deserve that
you're just like the best version of a
human being you know it's like girl you
know i know
you know television has changed the way
that politics works the internet has
changed you have you had to be telegenic
and then you had to be charismatic and
then you had to be
you know good at social media then you
had to be good at there's so much that
goes into it but it's like
you're just the best of every you know
version of this and i think people you
know
we do this in comedy and we do this in
politics as well politics as well where
we assume that
people are dumb they're stupid they're
easy to manipulate and
in some cases yeah it's easy to you know
get people to click on fake news and to
believe things that aren't true
by no fault of their own um necessarily
i have compassion for them but like
you know people i operate that people
are smart they see through bullshit
you know and you just are people are
smart
uh people are smarter so this is and
this is a big theme and something i'm
i i mean i'd love to have your help
working on some of these issues whitney
because you're seeing it all like the
data
the media uh the the fact that our
legislators are
you know very very disconnected i'm
trying to fix it all
and um and this last couple of years
made a lot of progress learned a lot i
feel like i've advanced universal basic
income to a point where
i believe that we're going to get it
done and yeah and but then these
structural problems
are both in the way and also independent
of it
um so and we need to get things in the
zeitgeist really quick we need to get
the
people like us have to connect because i
remember when michelle obama
um their last year in office she did a
conference call with show runners
and a bunch of us show owners got on a
call and she said
now um we can make a direct link
between the mass the passage of marriage
equality
and the tv show will and grace wow
so what we are putting in people's homes
every day someone that doesn't know a
gay couple that's you know and then they
you know are put in the position of you
know should gay people be able to get
married they're like yeah will of course
he should love that guy
you know he's been in your living room
you know every night for eight years so
the things that we put in our shows the
things we talk about you know in our
stand-up like to just
really does insert things in a
conversation you know i should be making
a show where we talk about
you know data being sold you know we
have to get it into
the conversation um with people that
make television and the things that are
you know going into people's brains
every day so it's top of mind
so people can i talk to folks i want
it's one reason why i love talking to
people like you who are the leading
storytellers
cribs people like you end up
teaching a lot of folks about you know
the world we live in
but i agree with you that people are
fundamentally smart and the big fear i
have around
the media so this is something that that
you know like some people want you know
whatever um so
uh so i've been looking into our trust
in the media
um so the trust in the media has been
declining probably not shocker to people
uh watching and listening to this but
it's been declining differently among
different
subsets of us so republicans trust in
media has plummeted to something like
you know 15
20 like they just don't trust anything
independent step fox news and sean
hannity and
infowars even then they'd be like oh
these assholes
then independence it's
uh let's call it uh 40 or so
and then which is about the national
average i think our trusted media is
around 41
not very good um and then among
democrats it's something like 65.
um so what you have is you have
a whole chunk of the country let's call
them democrats
who trust the media yeah uh and then the
media is
telling them things and then that
there's like this circle and then
there's a
then there are republicans who don't
believe any of it it's like oh you're
all full of shit
and then the independents are somewhere
between but all of the stuff is trending
down
yeah and so the thing that scares the
shit out of me
is that you're going to end up with a
subset of the population that's like
in this you know in this echo chamber
that is essentially
like our national conversation and then
more and more americans are slipping out
of it
and the incentives of the media
companies are tied up with
keeping their own audience vibrant and
whole
for their advertisers and the fact that
it's declining
like is just something to them it's like
an inconvenience because a lot of these
audiences have been declining for
a while because of technology and the
rest of it so
this is a disaster in the making where
you have uh
you and and this is one of the reasons
why our integrity as a society seems so
low seems like it's slipping away
seems like we can't reach everyone right
and the folks that you are trying to
reach through these messages
like are getting less and less trusting
of it because it's like oh i don't
believe you anymore i don't know
you and and and then you're going to
have this this subset that
it's like well i believe i believe why
don't you believe
that like that is yeah like that is a
disaster in the making and this to me is
something
we've been experiencing so the fact that
no one knows if they're supposed to wear
masks or not i mean it's just sort of
like
i'll send an article to someone they'll
send another one back that contradicts
the very thing that i just sent
and you know and and you know there's so
much dishonesty when they say like
covet has gone up 50 in this era it's
like you're a math person i'm really not
i just go 50
that's a huge number and then it's like
it's gone from one to two cases and
you're like that's
okay that definitely
uh blew that out of proportion type
thing so i think everyone is so
suspicious but i think that because
you know it's no accident that young
people i think it was something like 50
of people this was a couple years ago
we're getting their news from jon
stewart
you know because it's like at least i
can trust this person you know
yes back to storytellers comedians
and entertainers i think that
we have to come together and try and
figure out how we can
restore a sense of trust in
each other and the information we're
getting and that's not something and
this is what frustrates the hell enemies
like most people who say this
it's like hey we need to restore your
trust well that's great
i agree uh it's like you know what
that's going to require that's going to
require
actually investing billions of dollars
in like you know
infrastructure national service programs
universal basic income
and it like an information
uh set of incentives that make it so
that if i
give you an hour-long conversation and
it was shitty for ratings
i could still do that because we
actually thought you might
like get something positive out of it
instead of just freaking like you know
peppering you with the same freaking um
you know high stimulation uh type of
segments
so so that the the restoration of trust
is like a massive massive investment and
i'm hopeful that joe and kamala
end up being people that can help
uh make that case where we're going to
need to invest trillions of dollars in
ourselves
in our society and folks who don't think
that's possible i just always tell them
it's like look you remember voting for
the 4 trillion
bailout of wall street like you know 08
and then people are like
no i never voted for that it's like yeah
so you know who would you rather
like and i guess i think about it as i'm
talking to you and as i'm
thinking through this as someone who's
not a media strategist
is it just a comedian who makes
observations you know like i think a big
part of restoring
people say how can you restore trust in
politicians i think it's like this i
think it's comedian
having podcasts and having politicians
or people like yourself come on and have
thorough conversations in-depth
conversations i know i have to let you
go soon
but not just these five-minute bites
here or there you know it's like you
going on rogan that's how i'm going to
build trust in you that's how i'm going
to really understand how you think
and so i think that people like you
coming on podcasts is part of how this
changes
wow i should go on podcast more often
i'm just saying
people come here because they don't
trust cnn they don't trust msnbc they
want to just hear a human being talk and
they don't want to be pandered to they
don't want to be
manipulated or beguiled or you know they
don't want to hear like a bunch of
jargon they don't understand and see
someone in a super expensive suit they
can't afford they want to see a guy
in his basement in his t-shirt with his
like this is like i trust this guy you
know and this is a human being i want to
elect human beings i don't want to
you know elect some sort of narcissist
with wearing a suit that i could never
afford you know i think people just want
this sort of feels like the new town
hall you know you're going to be in
you know talking to me in someone's car
or a trucker or a mom driving her kid to
school or whatever and gets to
you know hear you answer questions
honestly i don't think there are nine
publicists behind the camera you're
looking at holding up signs telling you
what to say you're just
can't say there aren't
well whitney i um i'd love to do this
again because i
i feel like uh you know like i did a lot
of talking this time and i
appreciate it but you know i i'm
thrilled to be in touch and if you think
this stuff's good for
the country like sign me up uh because i
i'd love talking to folks like you
you're a real voice of reason and
clarity
it makes me glad that we're connected
now even though
it's been you know half the time i hear
moderators ask questions i'm like
no one's speaking for just kind of the
ever i don't like to say
you know average people i you know i
like that in your uh your book was the
war on normal people i hate when people
say average you know it seems so
pejorative but yeah just like normal
people's everyday question of like
you know where are my google searches
going are they selling my data to
insurance companies you know
um you know to be able to have those
conversations and you know it seems like
millionaires ask millionaires questions
that's kind of what
you know the news does and you know i
think on this show i really
you know and normal people are looking
up being like none of this means
anything to me anymore
and you're like yeah you're right it
doesn't because our system now
only cares about the almighty dollar and
if you
don't have uh enough of those and we
don't care about you
yeah again that that's the way and we
know now we know that that's a
pre-approved news anchor whose tweets
were vetted with pre-approved questions
with pre-approved answers
everything feels so scripted and you
know i think podcasts are changing the
way
you know we gather our information and
and connect to people and
um you know so what an honor thank you
for doing it i hope you do it more i
think that
this exact thing is what's going to
restore trust in politicians and raise
awareness about the things that actually
matter because these are comprehensive
well thank you for the opportunity
whitney and uh hopefully we'll be able
to hang out in person after
uh all of this stuff passes but if not
if we're in this
mess for a long time longer we'll do
another virtual conversation yes i have
a billion more questions for you i know
everyone's gonna have a billion more
questions for you but thank you for
letting me um of course take up a little
extra of your time we got 12 minutes
more than we should have guys my
podcasts are usually like four hours so
this is gonna be like you know well
that's one reason why i felt actually
like self-conscious that i feel like i'm
abbreviating a little bit because you're
the kind of person i could talk to for
four hours
uh but if anyone wants to see what i'm
up to
my organization's called humanity
forward it's called
movehumanityforward.com
uh we've given out eight million dollars
in economic relief because andre yang's
all about getting money to the people
uh we have this data dividend project
that when he described
uh have our own podcast which is not as
funny as whitney's um
data dividend it is so it and you are so
great at
naming things as well um i'm into
obvious names yeah
that that's my gift you don't overthink
it make it super clear andrew yang on
his
instagram it's it's you know everyone
has their own channel now which is the
great thing about
social media i know there's a lot of
downsides about it but the upside is you
know he's doing these incredible
interviews on his social media almost
every day you've got a new live or
um a video from your podcast your
twitter is incredible i must say your
twitter
is a breath of fresh air it's always so
positive it's so clear
it's a nice break in the toxic
mess that is twitter um follow him on
twitter follow him on instagram
and you know buy the books which we're
gonna you know talk about more in the
intro and please run for president
again thank you whitney if i do
we're going to have a party in the white
house your wife has probably
had it and i also may please say with
the last last thing
um your wife evelyn is unbelievable um
as someone that is uh
a survivor i followed her journey very
closely and she is absolutely incredible
um everyone look up evelyn yang and her
journey and her bravery and her courage
um i would love to have her on the
podcast at some point as well soon i
feel like i'm already pushing i feel
like i'm already pushing it no
i will i will ask her because she's a
huge fan of yours
um and yeah like i was so proud of her
and it was i mean it was something that
i i'd obviously
shared with her like you know as her
husband
beforehand and then i and i was like
look if you
obviously it's like whatever you wanted
yeah like i am 100
behind you but i was so proud of her and
uh
so angry at uh
the doctor and the folks that made it
possible
uh and so that there was so much of me
that was uh
like i i frankly i didn't want to be
like baby i want you to fucking rain
hellfire
but because you don't you don't want to
be like you know so i was just like
always like
like uh you know yeah 100 supportive but
i was so proud of her and and sharing a
story about
um you know an assault that you
experienced you know there's so much
embarrassment and shame and
fear and you know i can only imagine the
amount of anger
and rage you know that you felt but the
way that you supported her through that
and the way that
she walked through that with such grace
was incredibly inspiring to me and i
know
changed a lot of people's lives thank
you thank you yeah i'll thank her for
you whitney it was
i mean it was wild because like i felt
so much sadness before
and then like you kind of relived it
because you know
then it was
something that everyone knew about
yeah i'm just very appreciative uh of
evelyn i'm very very lucky to be married
to her
you i agree i agree she's unbelievably
so strong so resilient um you know as
someone that
you know constantly struggles with how
to speak about things like that
um watching her interviews and watching
the grace that she navigated it with
um and the elegance and the bravery
and the courage made me think oh you
know
we we can do this we can speak out
without um
making a mess of ourselves or
embarrassing ourselves or seeming like a
squeaky wheel you know it felt like just
the way that she navigated that
made me less scared about you know
talking about my experiences and i know
that it um
i'm i'm so glad and when she was on the
trail too she got that
uh from women everywhere we went
uh it was beautiful she wasn't someone
who
was frankly seeking the public eye at
all
i think people understood that um and
it's one reason why people appreciated
her coming forward is that it it seemed
um just not like she wanted to help
yeah and it was really touching because
everywhere we went there was just so
much appreciation for and it started a
lot of conversations with you know a lot
of my girlfriends a lot of my family
members going oh
i never thought about that but now that
i heard her talk about you know so
i think she really um is a very powerful
healer
in the things that she did i'm sure
there are some days it seems thankless
and some days that
you know it seems exhausting but um she
really has healed so many people
you know just in my immediate proximity
so um
i hope that one day i'll get to have her
on oh i'll there yeah
i'll ask her i'll ask her later yes yes
and if she says no
then you'll know i love her anyway
hopefully i'll just get to meet her and
give her a big hug when this whole
nightmare
uh is over i love you i am such a big
fan i am gonna harass you and force you
to do this again
um i love you so much thank you i've
already taken up too much of your time
um thank you whitney you're the best
i'll see you soon
love you too love you andrew yay
[Applause]